Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Good morning church. Happy Sunday.
It is awesome to be here with you.
Um, uh, my name is Brandon.
I get to serve here in the student ministry
and in the the residency program as well.
And so as always, shout out to students.
Um, yeah, they're the best.
Uh, if you are new here, I just want to take some time
to just say welcome.
Uh, there are a lot of great churches in this area
and if we can help you in any way, just show you
and, uh, share who we are and what we're about.
We'd love to help you in that process
of, uh, finding a church.
And there's a communication card
and the seat back, uh, right in front of you.
Or, uh, you can go out into the lobby
to our New Year section.
Uh, if you meet a man named Jimmy,
please tell him I said The bears are awful.
Um, and if you meet someone named Amy, please tell her
to tell Jimmy that the bears are awful.
Um, but a little bit about me, uh, is
that I grew up in a pretty quiet home.
Um, my, my father wasn't around.
My mom worked two jobs and, and I was the only child.
And so, so it was quiet for the most part.
And as an only child,
whenever I wasn't talking to the wall, uh, I caught myself,
uh, getting fascinated by stories.
And so, you know, stories have a lot of different purposes.
They can teach us things. They can help us remember things.
They can give us something to, uh, believe in.
And whether you're an only child
or not, uh, no matter what your background is,
everyone loves a good story.
And so we've all grown up hearing stories.
And you might be familiar with a famous story of
a lumberjack and his rusty trusty sidekick
ox Paul bunion.
And babe, let's see if it's, yeah, I had
to find the manliest picture I could of, of Paul Bunion.
Uh, yeah. So there we go. Paul Bunion.
And babe, you may remember the story.
Well, uh, maybe you haven't heard the story
of Paul Bunion since you were in second grade,
and which whichever camp you fall in, don't worry.
I'm gonna give you guys just a quick recap of who Paul is.
Here's some things we learned from his life.
When Paul was a child, his breakfast would consist
of milk, eggs, and potatoes.
Normal breakfast. I know nothing special about that.
But for Paul, his parents would need
to provide at least 10 cows, 50 eggs
and 10 potatoes a day to satisfy his hunger.
Every day was bulking season for Paul.
And Paul was so large that
whenever he would roll out of bed,
he would cause an earthquake to go through the entire town.
And as he grew older, we see that Paul had the strength
of 10 men and he was faster than the speed of light.
And from this point on, it only seems fitting to refer to,
refer to Paul as Mr.
Bunion because if he is this strong
and this powerful,
then he deserves our respect and our reverence.
Right? And as Mr.
Bunyan's journeys continue, it is rumored that him
and his sidekick ox, uh, dug out the Great Lakes
and they, they, some say they were responsible
for creating the Puget Sound just outside of Seattle.
And along the way, they cleared the trees in North
and South Dakota.
Mr. Bunion and Babe were a duo to be feared,
and they were so legendary
that people had even made songs about them.
People will always be able to remember who Mr. Bunion was.
And there are so many other stories
that we grow up listening to that captivate our attention.
They give us a character who does these, uh,
miraculous things that just leave us in awe.
Sometimes they do things so good that,
that we write songs about them.
You can think of Frodo and Lord of the Rings
or maybe even Han Solo when he made the Kels run
and less than 12 Parex.
And everyone loves and knows Spider-Man.
And as amazing and as breathtaking
as these stories are, they aren't real.
Most of these stories are simply a fantasy.
Mr. Bunion did not roll out of bed
and cause earthquakes and hurricanes.
At best, he was probably just an above average lumberjack.
These stories are simply exaggerations.
But can I tell you about a story
that is not an exaggeration?
Can, can I tell you about something
that has actually happened that should leave us
in wonder in adoration?
Can I, can I tell you about a moment that caused ASAP
to write a song so that Israel would never forget?
Please join me in Psalm 76 as we look at God's word together
and see what he has done.
Psalm 76,
God's word says this to the choir, master
with stringed instruments, a psalm of asap,
a song in Judah.
God is known, his name is great in Israel.
His abode has been established in Salem,
his dwelling place in Zion.
There he broke the flashing arrows, the shield, the sword,
and the weapons of war.
Glorious are you
more majestic than the mountains full of prey?
The stout hearted were stripped of their spoil
and they sank into sleep.
All the men of war went, were unable to hue their hands.
Etcher, rebuke, oh God of Jacob, both rider
and horse lay stunned.
But you, you are to be feared.
Who can stand before you when once your anger is roused
from the heavens, you utter judgment.
The earth feared and was still when God arose
to establish judgment,
to save all the humble of the earth.
Surely the wrath of man shall praise you.
The remnant of wrath will, you will put on like a belt,
make your vows to the Lord your God and perform them.
Let all around him bring gifts to him who is to be feared,
who cuts off the spirit of princes, who is to be feared
by the kings of the earth.
Let's pray. Lord, would you help us?
Would you help us to Lord, see who you are?
Lord, would you help us to respond accordingly?
Lord, I pray for our hearts. God, would you transform them?
Lord, let this not just be another thing that we do, God,
but Lord, would you grow us
into the image of your son Jesus.
In your name we pray, amen.
So we see at first Lance that this is a song.
We see that in the subscription we see, this is a song
that is communicating what God has done.
And this is a song that's based off of, based off a story.
And so why has ASAP chosen to write a song
and what is he seeking to communicate?
Well, the first thing we should note is that we should see
how ASAP sets the stage.
We should see how ASAP sets the stage of this,
this story, this song.
And, and as I read this text, I I can imagine
Asaf getting all the people of Israel together and,
and drawing them close as they were near a campfire,
as he goes on about who God is.
In the same way we have grown up hearing stories
of fantasies, myth like Paul bunion
here ASAP wants the people of God to come together
and recount his wonderful deeds.
And and I, uh, reading this, I think it's important to know
that he doesn't seem to be, uh, teaching them something
that they're completely unaware of.
I think the opposite is true.
ASAP expects his listeners to know who God is already
He, he has come to know
that God is a household name at this point.
We see that in verse one.
He says, in Judah, God is known,
but not only is he known, but his name is great
and it isn't revealed just
yet why his name is great, why he's known.
But he's getting to that. And not only does he share
who God is, but also where God is.
We see that in verse two, that, uh, the Lord has chosen
to establish himself in Salem and in Zion,
and it's easy to just fly over, fly over verse two.
But of all the places the great
and powerful known God would dwell, he chooses to dwell
with his people
and ASAP wanted people to see this
and to be reminded of who their God is
and what he has done.
And as he sets the stage, he references something
that God has done in the past.
We see that in verse three.
He says there, he broke the flashing arrows, the shield,
the sword, and the weapons of war.
There seems to be some context to this psalm.
There seems to be a situation
where God fought a battle on behalf of his people.
And the good news is, is that is a story
that we see all throughout scripture.
The not so good news is, is it may be harder for us to know
where exactly he is referring to because it is so common.
But there's a situation.
But two Kings chapters 18 and 19 that looks very similar.
And this could be where he's drawing this story from.
We don't know for certain,
but we are gonna go look at two Kings 18 and 19.
And instead you have a bookmark.
Go ahead and place it in Psalm 76
and we're gonna look at two kings for a bit
starting in verse 18.
You are looking at chapters 18 and 19.
And there's a lot in these chapters.
We're not gonna look at every verse, uh,
I just wanna highlight some of them
and kind of summarize what we see.
Two Kings 18, we are introduced
to a new king named Hezekiah.
And we learn in two Kings 18 verse three, it says that
speaking of Hezekiah, he did what was right in the eyes of
the Lord according to all that David his father had done.
And then if we keep moving in the text, we see
that Hezekiah trusted in the Lord, the God of Israel,
so that there were none like him among all the kings
of Judah after him, nor among those who were before him.
Not only does this text communicate
that he trusted in the Lord, he trusted in Yahweh,
but it even shows actions that he did as a king
to show his trust, to show his faith in Yahweh.
And we should remember the importance
of him trusting in the Lord as the story progresses.
So we're introduced to a king who trusts in the Lord above
all things, but we're also introduced to a king.
But the King of Assyria named Sin
and the Assyrians, they,
they were a powerful force at this time.
We can see in the description in two Kings 18, nine
and 12 of of their most recent conquest of Samaria
and how they took it and took all the Israelites with them.
But as mighty as this army was as mighty as the, the king
of Assyria felt at the time, king Aki is choosing
to rebel against them.
Well, why is that? Because the text has made it clear
that Hezekiah was going to trust in the Lord
above all things he was not going to submit
to a king with a big army.
And Sonka rib responded accordingly.
And in most circles we see that not only is son the king,
but he refers to himself as the great King.
And this is what the messenger of the great king
of Syria has to say to the people of Judah.
Starting in verse 28, look with me two kings
1828.
And as we read it, imagine how proud
or stouts they might be communicating this message.
Then the Rika stood
and called out in a loud voice in the language of Judah.
Hear the word of the great king, the king of Assyria,
thus says the king, do not let Hezekiah deceive you
for he will not be able to deliver you out of my hands.
Do not let Hezekiah make you trust in Yahweh
by saying Yahweh will surely deliver us.
And this city will not be given into the hand
of the king of Assyria.
Do not listen to Zeki. For thus says the king of Assyria.
Make your peace with me and come out to me.
Then each one of you will eat of his own vine
and each one of his own fery.
And each one of you will drink the water of his own system
until I come and take you away to a land like your own land,
a land of grain and wine, a land of bread
and vineyards, a land of olive trees
and honey that you may live and not die.
And do not listen to zeki when he misleads you by saying
that Yahweh will deliver us.
Has any of the gods
of the nations ever delivered his land out of the hand
of the king of Assyria?
Where are the gods of heath in our pod?
Where are the gods of ship? Vem and Hena and Eva?
Have they delivered Samaria out of my hands?
Who among all the gods
of the land have delivered their lands out of my hands
that the Lord should deliver Jerusalem out of my hands?
According to Sinna rib
and all the Assyrians, there is nothing, there is no one
who can deliver Jerusalem out of his hands.
He refers back to the conquest of Samaria, any,
and he asked, did anyone deliver them out of my hands
because of this power?
And because of this, the might he feels on top of the world,
he feels like Jack in the Titanics.
I'm the king of the world.
And in some ways he, he's challenging Yahweh.
He is seeking to stand before Yahweh and contend with him.
Now, you can imagine how Hezekiah might have responded
and all who heard this news, they saw
what they were up against.
They no doubt heard the stories of their recent conquest.
So how did they respond? They knew this was beyond them.
Did they give into Assyria?
No, that's not the story that we see.
They continue to trust in the Lord
and they turn their face to God in prayer.
They turn their face to the one who is mightier than this.
So-called Great king
has a guy continued to trust in Yahweh above
all things he didn't trust in horses, in armies or chariots,
but in the Lord.
And this is how Yahweh responds in two kings, uh,
19 versus six
and seven, Isaiah said
to them, say to your master, thus says the Lord,
do not be afraid because of the words that you have heard
with which the servants of the king
of Assyria have revived me.
Behold I will put a spirit in him so
that he shall hear a rumor and return to his own land
and I will make him fall by the sword in his own land.
Yahweh intervenes.
Yahweh sees the proud and he humbles them.
Yahweh declares judgment on the evil doers.
Yahweh hears the prayers of his people and he answers them.
And if we go back to Psalm 76 verse one, we can see
and believe if this is why God is known in Judah,
this is why his name is great
because there he broke the flashing garros there,
he broke the shield, the sword, and the weapons of war.
And we can see this is how the story ends
for Assyria two Kings 1932 through 37.
Therefore, thus says the Lord concerning the king of
Assyria, he shall not come into this city
or shoot an arrow there or come before it with a shield
or cast up a siege mound against it by the way that he came
by the same way he shall return
and he shall not come into this city declares the Lord,
for I will defend this city to save it for my own sake
and for the sake of my servant David.
And that night, the angel of the Lord went out
and struck down 185,000 in the camp of the Assyrians
when the people arose early in the morning,
behold these were all dead bodies.
The S rib King of Assyria departed and went home
and lived at Nineveh.
And as he was worshiping in the house of NIST rock, his God
and a germane
and Sha Azi, his son struck him down with the sword
and escaped into the land of RA
and radan his son reigned in his place.
So why does any of this matter?
What does this have to do with our text in Psalm 76?
Well, I believe ASAP wanted the people to see what God has
done ASAP wanted them to see what Yahweh has
done, knowing what God has done leads them
to praise God.
Knowing what God has done leads them to sing songs
and to worship him like the legend of Mr.
Bunion. But real, the the story
of God's wondrous works is not one of fiction and fantasy,
but one of reality and power.
So let's jump back to Psalm 76
and look at the imagery that is hus in verses four
through six and see how it compares to
what we just read in two kings,
the song here says that Yahweh is more glorious
and more majestic than the mountain's fool of prey.
This could be referring to the multitude of their army
that they were up against.
We see here that the stout hearted were stripped
of their spoil and they sank in to sleep.
We see in two Kings 19 that 185,000 of them were struck down
and they were all dead in the morning.
We see that all the men of war were unable
to use their hands.
And what did the Lord say?
He said that they shall not come into this city
or shoot an arrow or come before with a shields.
There was nothing that these men were able to do
because of the rebuke of the Lord.
They were all stunned.
And this is what Yahweh has done
and this is what ASAP wants the people to see
and reflect on.
And there's a purpose behind that.
But before we get to that, I wanna just pause
and ask a couple questions.
Do you reflect on the things of God?
Do you reflect on the things that God has done in your life?
Have you ever found yourself in a situation like has Aki
where it might have seemed like all hope was lost
and it forced you to turn your face to God in prayer?
And let me ask, do you ever go back
and reflect on those moments
and think about how Yahweh showed up?
What is your story that testifies
of God's faithfulness?
And I want to challenge you to reflect on these things
because it reflect on as often as possible
because I myself suffer from something that has,
has been self diagnosed, but I just can't remember it.
And, and I'm this is, this is embarrassing actually.
Uh, I'm forgetting what it, what it's called.
Uh, John talked about it last week.
I, I think about remembering
and forgetting things, something to do with with God.
Uh, yes. Spiritual amnesia. Yes.
And if I had to guess,
I'm probably not the only person in the room
who suffers from that.
I'm probably not the only person in this room who tends
to forget what God has done.
And I know for a fact
that I'm not the only person in history
because as I look through the Bible, I see people
who are are constantly forgetting what God has done.
We see it in the Exodus as the people are walking
through the wilderness, they're grumbling
and they're complaining and they want to go back
to being enslaved after they just saw God do these
wonderful deeds.
We see it in the transition from Joshua to judges.
We see a nation that followed the Lord, who made a covenant
with the Lord at the very end
and the next book we see in judges
and it did not take long for them to do
what was right in their own eyes.
This is why we should reflect on what Yahweh has done.
This is why ASAP wants the people to be reminded.
This is why he writes this song of this story so
that they will know and remember forever who Yahweh is.
But he doesn't stop there.
Look with me verses seven through nine, as we
see why Yahweh has done it, we see
what Yahweh has done,
but why has Yahweh done it?
In this text, we see a lot of powerful language.
We see that at God's rebuke, both rider
and horse lay stunned.
We see that in in verse six, in verse seven,
we see God's anger roused that when his anger is roused that
that no one can stand before him.
In verse eight
and nine, we see that God had uttered judgment.
And then in verse nine, we see God establish, come through
with that judgment.
And if the context of this psalm is actually what happened
with King Hezekiah, then we see God wipe out one
of the most powerful armies at that time.
And here in this psalm, it seems like this act
of judgment is something to be celebrated
and to be remembered for generations to come
and, and the reason why they are celebrating
what God has done and reflecting on it is
because of what we see in verse nine.
Verse nine says this, when God arose
to establish judgment to save all the humble of the earth,
we see the purpose behind why Yahweh has done it.
The all powerful God has used this power to save the humble
of the earth and to deliver them out of the hand
of their enemies.
This is what we see in Hezekiah's life and his story.
We see this, this humility shown as he trusts in the Lord,
as he turns his face to him instead of trusting in himself,
trust in Yahweh.
But on the flip side, we see a king
who doesn't trust in the Lord, who isn't very humble,
who refers to himself as the great king
and he stands against God, he contends with God.
And Sinna Rip should have known that God is in the business
of humbling, the proud and exalting the humble.
But as I read this text, it, it seems very straightforward
that God came to save a humble folk like us
and judge the stout hearted who who live outside
of these walls.
This is why Yahweh has done it.
He has done it to save a humble people like us.
So let's, let's praise him.
But as I read this text
and I'm honest with myself, that's not me.
When I look at verse nine nine when it says
to save all the humble of the earth, that's not me.
I am not a man who falls into the camp of humility,
of humble of the earth.
If I'm being honest with myself, I relate more
with Sinna rib than King Hezekiah.
I fall into the camp of the proud
and God opposes the proud.
And we see from this text
and all throughout scripture that judgment is coming
for the proud judgment is coming for those
who stand in opposition of Yahweh.
And so why has Yahweh done these acts?
Why has Yahweh's anger been roused?
Why is judgment coming to condemn the mighty
and to save the humble?
What that means is that judgment is coming.
And I don't think the Psalm shies away from that
judgment is coming for all those who are opposed
to God.
And scripture is clear that all have sinned
and all have followed the prince of this world
and disobedience, all of us stand in opposition to God.
So what are we to do?
How are we to sing a song that's late,
that's laid out here in Psalm 76?
How are we to celebrate what Yahweh has done
and why he has done it when we stand guilty before him?
Well, I believe the answer comes from
a humble man, not Hezekiah,
but someone who would come through the line of
Hezekiah would come from his lineage
and that someone is named Jesus.
Here's what we learn about Jesus in Matthew one.
Verse 21 says that she will bear a son
and you shall call his name Jesus,
for he will save his people from their sins.
Jesus will save his people from their sins.
Jesus will save us from our pride.
Jesus will save us from the judgments of God the Father,
by taking on the judgment of the Father.
He did that by being the only man
who walked in perfect humility.
He did that by being the humble of the earth.
He did that by walking in perfect obedience
to God the Father.
He constantly trusted in the Father above all things.
And for that he deserves every blessing imaginable.
But instead, we see that he willingly went to the cross
and took on all the wrath of the Father that was due to us.
He took on the judgment that we deserve so
that we could be saved
and be in right relationship with the Father.
And if you are in this room today
and you have confessed with your mouth
and belief in your heart that Jesus is Lord
and that God has raised him from the dead,
then you will be saved.
And then you can read Psalm 76 with great joy
and celebrate what Yahweh has done and why he has done it.
Because God is in the business of saving people,
saving the humble because of
what Christ has done on our behalf.
So if all this is true, if Yahweh is the one
who is more majestic
and more glorious in the mountains full of prey,
if at his rebuke both rider and horse lay stunned.
If Yahweh has done all these things to save the humble
of the earth, what should our response be?
What is this song wanting us to see?
I believe Psalm 76 put puts all this in front of us so
that we can see that Yahweh is the name
above all names.
That he is the one to be feared.
Yes, he is the one to be feared.
Let's look and see how this song wrap seven
verses 10 through 12.
Surely the wrath of man shall praise you, the remnant
of wrath you will put on like a belt.
Make your vows to the Lord your God and perform them.
Let all around him bring gifts to him, is to him who is
to be feared, who cuts off the spirit of princes, who is
to be feared by the kings of the earth.
In the same way we all growing up, we all grow up hearing
and watching stories that take our breath away
and leave us in awe.
The same way I joke about referring to Paul bunion as Mr.
Bunion and saying that he should be feared.
ASAP expects the people to be left in awe struck wonder of
what Yahweh has done.
We see in verse sin that the wrath of man shall praise you,
meaning that Yahweh will be praised even
by those whose intent was not to praise him.
In verse 11, Asaf says that people should bring their vows
and gifts before the one who is to be feared.
Well, what does he mean when he talks about this word? Fear?
What does it mean to fear the Lord?
I don't think he desires people to be a people
to be afraid of God.
Not not God's people.
But in Hebrews 1228 to 29, it says this,
therefore, let us be grateful for receiving a kingdom
that cannot be shaken
and thus let us offer to God acceptable worship
with reverence and awe for our God is a consuming fire,
worship, reverence, and awe because his name is great,
because he is glorious and majestic,
because he arose to establish judgment
and to save all those who are his
because Yahweh is the name above all names.
And this is a story to be remembered forever.
This is a song that will be sung forever.
This is a story that should leave us in awe
and entice us to praise him forever.
Psalm 76, in Judah, God is known,
his name is great in Israel.
His abode has been established in Salem,
his dwelling place in Zion.
There he broke the flashing garros to shield the sword
and the weapons of war.
Glorious are you
more majestic than the mountains full of prey?
The stout hearted were stripped of their spoil.
They sank into their sleep.
All the men of war were unable
to use their hands at your rebuke.
Oh God of Jacob, both rider and horse lay Duns.
But you, you are to be feared Who can stand
before you when once your anger is roused from the heavens,
you utter judgments.
The earth feared and was still when God arose
to establish judgment to save all the humble of the earth.
Surely the wrath of man shall praise you.
The remnant of wrath you'll put on like a belt.
Make your vows to the Lord your God and perform them.
Let all around him bring gifts to him who is to be feared,
who cuts off the spirit of princes, who is to be feared
by the kings of the earth.
Let's pray. Lord, would you
recapture our awe?
Would you recapture our wonder?
God, may we reflect on what you have done
and why you have done it?
May we sing your praises forever?
And your name we pray, amen.